[Musique]
samuel tavernier bonjour bonjour alain
livory bonjour à tous les martiniquais
et singulièrement tous les franciscains
qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui alors vous
mener la liste en laudebat l'amba
françois vous êtes arrivé en deuxième
position lors du premier tour vous avez
réalisé près de 36% des suffrages
exprimés soit environ 2200 s'ils voient
comment analysez vous ce premier tour
alors un premier taux qui est très
étroit gens pour nous le score lui même
parle de lui même on va dire si vous
voulez que nous avons réalisé une
superbe campagne vraiment nous sommes
très heureux il ya eu ce qu'on vide qui
est un peu j'ai tout le monde mais nous
particulièrement et je pense vraiment
que nous avons réalisé un superbe score
quand on compare le premier tour de 2014
et celui de 2020 on se rend bien compte
effectivement qu'à bien l'écart c'est
extrêmement resserré et il n'a presque
pas d'écart justement entre l'équipe
sortante et nous autrement dit
l'allemand guay ben vous avez parlé de
on se retrouve quasiment de même schéma
c'est vraiment un remake de 2014 une
triangulaire
c'est vrai que même candidat les mêmes
candidats mais avec des partitions
différentes premier au monde un candidat
de l'équipe sortante n'est pas le même
deuxièmement les quarts guen après il y
en a plus on va dire ça comme ça et n'a
plus entre nous et l'équipe sortante
puisque il ya un rattrapage qui a été
fait vous imaginez y avait plus de 20
points 20 26 points d'écart 2014 entre
nous il n'y a plus que deux points
d'écart
et l'autre chose importante c'est
effectivement que victor grandet le des
candidats qui n'est pas qualifié pour le
deuxième tour et bien dès le soir du
premier tour il nous a rejoints il est
avec nous et il a demandé à ses
électeurs
les 157 franciscains qui ont voté pour
lui de nous rejoindre vous voyez bien
que là aujourd'hui
les cartes ont été largement
redistribuer est toujours pas d'alliance
entre vous et kevin mousseau
non c'est son choix que je respecte
d'ailleurs lorsque l'issue est ce que
l'issue ne risque pas d'être la même
qu'en 2014
la victoire du mpf la différence c'est
que l'écart était tellement grand 2014
il y avait 1500 voit l'écart entre moi
et le candidat donc de l'équipe sortante
aujourd'hui on n'est pas vraiment dans
les mêmes vous êtes environ 130 voix
cette voix et comme je vous le disais
les voix de victor grandin
mathématiquement puisqu'il faut quand
même en tenir compte
eh bien nous placent déjà et bien très
bonne position donc vraiment les les
conditions ne sont pas les mêmes et
c'est pourquoi nous disons que même si
karine mousseau et là elle voilà c'est
son droit et là nous sommes en
démocratie elle se représente
mais là aujourd'hui la victoire est
vraiment à notre portée
alors si vous êtes élu maire quel sera
votre grand projet quels seront vos
grands axes les cosaques sont connus
depuis le premier tour et par parler
francis caisse nous parlons
d'aménagement de ce bourg parce que de
cette commune plutôt puisqu'on voit bien
que les problèmes que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui sont dues à un aménagement
et courir donc fera remettre un peu
d'ordre dans tout ça et puis s'occuper
des franciscains parce que c'est vrai
quand on parcourt les quartiers le beau
on se rend compte qu'il ya beaucoup de
difficultés et placer les franciscains
est au centre de notre projet ça veut
dire au niveau social fait un travail
très important
les accompagner les orienter les aider
les franciscains qui sont en difficulté
et puis avec tout cela est bien remettre
la commune à l'endroit parce
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte que la
commune bien le développement a été
stoppé tout et en désuétude et il faut
effectivement pas construire rebâtir la
commune du françois
comment vous vivez ce second tour avec
toute cette pandémie
toute cette crise anitea comment ça se
passe pour vous la rencontre avec la
population comment vous organisez alors
c'est vrai que c'est une crise
exceptionnelle inédite qui a déboussolé
beaucoup d'entre nous
et puis aussi les aspects économiques
sociaux le lien social est distendu
aujourd'hui par rapport effectivement ce
confinement qui a duré trois mois
mais moi pendant toute cette période
eh bien je suis en même temps j'ai une
autre casquette celui de président du
centre social du monde en acajou et
centre social vous imaginez que nous
étions en première ligne pendant la
pandémie et nous avons effectivement
fait beaucoup d'action sur le territoire
français et même plus largement en
faveur de ses deux des habitants mais il
faut dire que cette crise ne nous a
permis effectivement d'avoir un regard
nouveau de réajuster le programme le
projet que nous avons déjà fait pour les
franciscains aujourd'hui on s'est bien
rendu compte qu'il ya des priorités au
niveau de l'action publique que nous que
nous comptons mener gaillac il a fallu
distribuer un petit peu les priorités et
aujourd'hui on se dit que ce qui est
important c'est la prise en compte de
l'humain la prise en compte de l'humain
à travers tout cela au niveau économique
également il y à un accompagnement une
orientation à donner à nos artisans par
exemple donc il y à il y a vraiment
cette crise parce que la crise en fait
elle était présente mais elle va durer
elle va durer et tout stif qui est fait
aujourd'hui c'est fait dans le cadre
effectivement de la gestion de la crise
mais nous pensons déjà à l'après crise
que ma compagne est encore léger merci
samuel tagliani
merci